how to stand out on social media as an
entrepreneur think about this year for a
moment I want you to think about if I
were to call you you if I were to call
you and say let's get together for
meeting
what's the meeting about I have an idea
I want us to start a media company
together
what do you mean Pat let's start a media
company together tell me about what you
mean let's start our own TV station
let's start our radio company okay on
radio station let's start our own
satellite where we can be anywhere live
and anybody can see it let's start our
newspaper our own magazine let's start
our own any our own mailing company to
send letters birthday cards anniversary
cards but let's start aching let's start
a massive media company together how
much money do you think you and I would
need to start that media company 10
million 20 million 30 50 I don't know
but I know the number is a pretty big
number to start the media company with
however here's the key today you and I
can start that media company for zero
here's why let me show social media a
lot of times people look at different
platforms and we use them but we don't
really know what it's about I'm going to
explain it you as an entrepreneur what
these platforms are to you as an
entrepreneur okay so how do you Inc
stand out how do you in stand out we
have eight platforms here blog Twitter
Instagram periscope YouTube podcasts
Facebook LinkedIn watch this newspapers
the old newspaper today is the blog it's
been replaced by the blog there used to
be a time with the journalists who work
for New York Times LA Times all this
stuff we're writing articles and people
read about it and share with other
people today newspapers have been
replaced by blogs who can start it
anybody you for free we read magazines
about gossip all this other stuff you
know to see who this person what this
person is doing entertainment all this
up today that's been replaced by Twitter
I use Twitter to follow news to see what
words are trending that is a free
platform to everybody Instagram we used
to have photo albums when's the last
time you and I bought a photo album it's
been replaced by instant
Ram and you know a picture says more
than words dude so we see pictures there
it tells us what's going on we follow it
live TV has been replaced by periscope
it's a free platform yesterday I'm
driving yes I am driving and I'm
listening to Donald Trump at the same
time announce his his new tax program if
he becomes the president I'm literally
watching it on periscope while driving
live TV I don't have access to this
before we were at Paris I'm on top of
the Eiffel Tower so I tried to see if
periscope works I turned on periscope
and I say I'm on top of eiffel tower
2,000 people within 20 seconds or
following me and I'm simply going like
this with the camera they're watching it
on periscope live TV there is no new
station there it's free satellite TV has
been replaced by YouTube depending on
what your market is you're going to see
more people watching youtube videos than
TV i watch more YouTube videos then I
watch television I don't watch
television anymore i watch you too I
know none of the shows on TV but I do
know different entrepreneurs different
Channel stations things on YouTube that
I watch radio stations have been
replaced by podcast if you look at radio
stations I was meeting with one of the
top executives of one of the largest
radio companies in the world today and
he and I had a meeting to get he was
telling me radio is on a downtick to the
point they don't want to report any more
how many listeners they have because if
you tell them how many more listeners
you have it's not the same anymore
podcast is free we used to not use
podcasts before and we just started our
podcast would you say six weeks ago five
weeks ago roughly six weeks ago five
weeks ago and it's getting us in a
platform we weren't a part of before
then you have Facebook hey there was a
time you wrote letters you wrote
birthday cards we wrote anniversary
cards we don't write it anymore you
simply go on Facebook you say happy
birthday happy Anniversary your kid
looks amazing I cannot believe what's
happened I miss you I feel like I see
you every day because I follow your kids
that's Facebook and then LinkedIn very
simple resumes and business cards have
been replaced by LinkedIn when I hire
somebody when I'm hiring somebody for
our company
go through LinkedIn and by the way every
one of these platforms I can give you
numerous stories of clients business
partners somehow someway somebody that I
did business with that I met through
here when I tell you I met through here
we're not talking five hundred thousand
dollars type of money we're talking lots
of money that was made through these
platforms that we met and help grow my
financial firm that I'm running with our
leaders it helped grow that platform PHP
agency'
because I realize if we're going to be
competitive and I'm competing you know
with four hundred billion dollar
companies six hundred billion dollar
companies they have a budget of two
billion dollars a year to do advertising
and sponsor some golf golf golf for
sponsors some basketball player or
football player we're a startup company
we get started with sixty agents in oh
nine and now we have eighteen hundred
agents in 37 states I can't go have 50
million to put into advertising this has
become the great equalizer versus going
against the bigger companies if you use
social media property so now many times
if you're new to social media maybe
you're dabbling in Facebook or something
but you're not necessarily fully and
you'll look at all this stuff and you'll
say my goodness this is just
overwhelming to me I feel like I want to
spend all day long just being on social
media this could be very overwhelming so
I'll hear people say I don't have the
time to do social media I don't have the
time to do this and these common
objections out here I'll address every
one of them with you here one of them
could be I don't have any time okay
I run a firm financial firm I have
employees staff agents attorneys
carriers partners after negotiate with
software I have all these other things
that I need to be doing on a daily basis
okay I need to travel go visit offices
go visit vendors all these things I need
to do I have a three and a half year old
I have a two year old I'm married I
create content I write books I have
family I need to spend time with go have
fun sporting units all this stuff travel
the world all this stuff there's still
time so every time I hear somebody say I
don't have the talent I think it's a
lack of efficiency so I'll tell you how
I do it
I blog I write an article a week minimum
on Sunday nights when everybody's asleep
I'll write typically at 11 o'clock at
night my wife's asleep kids are asleep
it's quite I got an hour and a half to
write an article I'll get on that right
and I'll send it out if you can do it
two three times a week that's more power
to you I do minimum of once a week
Twitter is very easy it takes 30 seconds
to a nap to a minute to send it to it
it's not that long but when I get up
early in the morning I'll normally go
through the news for about twenty to
thirty minutes on Twitter and I'll
follow the news in the morning 5:30 in
the morning six o'clock I'll get up and
I'll follow the news Instagram it's easy
one post a day that doesn't take a long
time to put periscope I do it maybe once
a week when I'm at a special place that
I'm doing periscope with it gets me into
a whole new marketplace YouTube will do
two videos a week regularly we do two
videos a week and that doesn't take a
long time and by the way before you stab
a whole camera set up all this stuff
this is how I got started with a regular
iPhone regular camera nowadays you can
do all these self as a matter of fact
it's more real when you do that way
anyways but you have content with this
anyway this camera used to be a $5,000
camera 20 years ago today it's called
the phone you can do that from anywhere
Podcast you'll need quiet time by
yourself Facebook once a day and
LinkedIn for me LinkedIn a lot of people
use LinkedIn quite a lot I'm not a big
LinkedIn person that I use it regularly
I have set up my LinkedIn and everything
else gets pushed to LinkedIn when people
want to find out who Patrick vid David
is they go here it's okay so I know who
Patrick Wayne if it is boom they leave
now if I post content on LinkedIn it's
maybe once or twice a week maybe once or
twice a week so my time being put into
LinkedIn is maybe maybe 10 minutes a
week maybe it's 10 minutes a week here
hour-and-a-half here 30 minutes in the
morning here for my news 5 minutes here
if I do video 15 minutes here per week
this will take me 2 hours per week if I
do one of these every other week say an
hour to two hours and that's another 10
minutes that's not a lot of time that's
a couple hours a week is what we're
talking about per week if you do so when
you say you don't have time you have
plenty of time to do it too
I hear some people's have a private
person well let me explain about the
private person I'm a very private person
myself as well but but I had to
differentiate between the two so let me
let me let me kind of explain what I
mean by this there's a big difference
between being private and between being
a marketer if you're private you don't
need to do a video and talk about your
personal life your marriage your
relationship you don't need to do that
if that's not what you want to do you
don't have to do that now if you're
going to create content for moms we have
my sister and and Marlene pauletta
Marlene they post mantra preneur that's
what they brought the other day Marlene
was over she had a shirt on called mom
tripping or my sister wears a shirt calm
entrepreneur so it's mom entrepreneur
they combine it together great so that's
what they're marketing maybe they'll
talk about I went today and saw my kids
and I did this and I was spending on my
kids and at the same time I run a
business if I wasn't an entrepreneur I
couldn't do this great that's what their
Brandon but if you don't want to brand
that you don't have to brand that your
personal life doesn't have to be told to
anybody however remember let's redefine
entrepreneurship real quick Paul and I
were talking earlier and I said to me
entrepreneurship is purely marketing and
he said so wouldn't you consider Steve
Wozniak an entrepreneur I said not I
don't think Steve Wozniak's an
entrepreneur here's why Steve Wozniak is
an engineer he happens to own a piece of
Apple but he's not a market he's not the
entrepreneur Steve Jobs is the
entrepreneur because he's the market or
he packaged this product in a way that
you and I want to buy he packaged this
in a way that you and I want to buy this
is the design this is marketing what's
inside of it is an engineer right so if
you're an entrepreneur and you're a
marketer you got to think like a
marketer as as private as you may be it
doesn't make your noggin you are not
going to make it as an entrepreneur if
you stop thinking of yourself as a
market or everything you got to think of
as marketing it's marketing its
marketing its marketing that you're
doing right your domain is marketing
what you do which leads to you selling
your product services to whoever it is
that you're marketing to so okay now
three how do I make money so that was
one of my questions when I first found
out about social network so how do
make money what's the purpose of doing
this what's the purpose of doing that
let me explain to you
I found one contact from here who
followed my YouTube videos who was
following me here and watching my
YouTube videos that one contact made me
a million dollars just telling you right
now this contact through here somebody
was watching videos made the company who
knows how much money over the next three
six twelve months because they saw the
content from here I got a contact from
here that came through a LinkedIn who
was watching the videos for four years
and all of a sudden that client came
made a few hundred thousand dollars to
the company people who read the articles
here they come back and they say how
like every one of these have made money
the purpose of you doing this it's not
for you to make you know 20 cents here
and by the way some people if you have
YouTube ads and you think you're gonna
make a lot of money on YouTube ads
what's the number where you can start
really making money on YouTube ads a
million views a day you got to get
million views a day to make $5,000
$10,000 a month the numbers are out of
control so you're not doing this to make
money from here you're doing this to
help your platform your base grow and
here's another thing TED Talks they had
a convention in a Seattle I believe and
and one of the gentlemen that got up and
spoke and he said the next 10 20 years
there's two things that's going to be
very valuable one is data two is
education so data is why did Facebook
pay billions for Instagram because they
have data they have data of billions of
pictures on there that's a lot of value
right why is certain companies like
Twitter no matter how much people bash
and say you know 80 percent of users on
Twitter are fake you know nowadays
you'll see people who have you know
three hundred eighty thousand followers
there is now apps that you can go audit
that person on what percentage of their
followers are accurate followers what is
that a web is a twig Twitter audit yeah
Twitter on it Paul can we put a link
just put a put a picture of what Twitter
audit looks like on the website so they
can see it on the video and let's put
the link on the bottom that they can go
to Mari let's make sure to do that
Twitter audit matter of fact go on that
Lincoln check on some people you leave
for yourself some people you work with
and check on them and see what
percentage of their followers are valid
followers or not
politicians got cut because they bought
you know 600,000 followers were fake
followers nowadays you can buy that for
$100 but people are starting to realize
what's fake and what's real so you don't
need to fabricate your following there
right so but it's about education and
data so the more you create education on
your videos or your blog you're
educating people that is data to you
that's content that's the future that's
why Khan Academy was picked up by Bank
of America and a partner because people
want routes on how to educate the world
you can actually do that with all the
free platform there you have here here's
another one people say no one knows who
I am no one else why I have a friend of
mine his name is Edwin Lopez good friend
he is by far the best detailer I've ever
dealt with ever his company's name is
artistic detailing can we put a picture
up of artistic detail he's the only
person in America that services five
Bugattis in the world he services five
Bugattis in the world now he gets paid
to $10,000 to service Bugattis he got
paid twenty thousand dollars because the
Bugatti owner wanted him to go and
travel with them all over the place but
he gets paid that kind of money and he's
incredible at what he does when he comes
on services our cars he cleans areas
that I don't even pay attention to but
when him and I spoke years back I said
listen brandy yourself go out there and
talk make yourself be noticed on
Instagram his business is purely through
Instagram his business is not through
Facebook Twitter
it's an Instagram driven product I think
he's got I don't know how many how many
followers does he have on Instagram
Marty we just say 20,000 followers
something like that let's put one of the
pictures up so people can see what kind
of likes artistic Auto Detailing he's
got 15,000 200 the followers I'll take
one of the pictures here's 600 likes
300 likes 220 likes 365 likes and that
got his brand to the point where you
know he's probably the most famous
celebrities detailer in Beverly Hills
everyone uses and he'll go to client's
house and he'll do 20 cars he used to be
small detail
for nothing and he is now big but he
leveraged Instagram there's another
person good friend of my Kelly Nishimoto
who has a brand her pants brand is
called cute booty my wife loves the
pants that she makes Kelly Nishimoto
started her brand and just recently I
think it was on Instagram when one of
the videos got 68 million views what was
it was a YouTube got 68 million views
and when that thing got 68 million views
they didn't have enough orders to take
because there were so many people
ordering her pants the quality's
incredible the materials incredible you
know it's something that can compete
against some of these other guys that I
actually think it's better than
Beachbody and some of these other brands
that are out there
what's the other one that the Lululemon
is a Lululemon that's out there as well
it's another brand that's out there it's
fun her brand is better than all of them
when you feel the quality if your lady
in your life let's put a picture up and
put a link to Chell inertia Moto's
website order one of her pants you'll
see what I'm talking about Andy Mason
good friend of mine Dean Mason his this
is a family to us we love DJ Dean Mason
he's probably one of the top 50 EDM of
DJs in the world this guy started small
we sat down at PF Changs probably four
years ago and I said you need to have a
bigger presence on social media his
Instagram today he puts pictures on
Instagram 1200 likes 1,500 likes in this
hat that you saw me wore on one of the
videos last week or two weeks ago
officially addicted this is his brand
this is his brand on what he's done but
he started small with social media and
it started expanding and he didn't know
a lot about social media he gradually
started growing out everybody in the EDM
world knows who he is he does events
where he does events in all over the
world he's done events he's phenomena
what he does and the last one I'll tell
you is that some people say I'm not good
with technology I'm just not a
technology person you know nowadays
think about before you have to learn how
to use the VHS you have to learn how to
use the TV you have to learn how to use
the remote control all this stuff you
have to learn how to use the radio you
have to learn how to use all of these
platforms today you have one tool you
need
on how to use this is it so when you say
you're not good with technology they
have made it so simple today that my
father who's 74 years old comes to me
and shows me some of the features on
apps that I don't even know about and he
used a social media giver let's give him
some love can't put a picture up though
my dad he's giving some love he's become
a social media guy he follows everything
on social my dad is on periscope can you
understand my dad seventy-four years old
using periscope right so when I hear
people telling me I'm too old I'm to
this I think when the best people right
now on social medias Donald Trump and
he's what 66 67 years old uses Twitter
better than you know 20 year olds use
Twitter uses Instagram Twitter periscope
Facebook YouTube blog he uses every
platform to get himself to where he's at
right now where he's running for his
campaign he doesn't need any fun then
why because 100 percent of his stuff is
based on his following that he is from
social media so now let's talk about how
do you actually go about standing out on
social media as an entrepreneur so let's
talk about that I got I got a few points
for you Candace it's specific points
that I'll go through one a one have a
message okay have a message slash
opinion so when I say a message is what
is your message going to be for instance
is it going to be financial advice real
estate advice health and fitness is it
going to be Entrepreneurship selling is
it going to be diet it doesn't matter
have something that your messages around
the more specific it is the better you
do there's a you can be general in
general is not going to get you what
you're looking for get as specific as
possible so if you can have 20 different
things you want to talk about bring it
back down to 10 bring you back down to 5
bring you downtown to 3 then pick the
number one thing and talk about that
make that your message number 2
value-based everything is about value if
I read something that's valuable you
know what I do I share it if I read a
blog from some of the others I read an
article that said up and let's post that
on the bottom as well this was a great
article the article was
you know something about why your car
has a lot to do with the success of your
business as an entrepreneur right so
this was a block that was written I
shared it it was shared 75 times or so
and that person who wrote that blog was
not on Forbes it was not a entrepreneur
or an Inc article that person
automatically he wrote the article okay
I'm one of the person that read it I
shared it on my platform and all of a
sudden he got noticed by this platform
so because he wrote that article I
shared it this mark this following is
now following him because she brought
value with the article that he wrote
very good article that he wrote right
let's give him some love on the bottom I
don't know who this person is who wrote
it it's a very good article that
everyone okay three target audience okay
let me explain to you what I mean by
target audience who is your audience
okay a lot of times the more specific
everything is about specific efficiency
specific message specific value that has
to do with the message specific target
audience who is your target audience
you're not trying to be everything to
everybody what is your target audience
you're not wanting everybody to agree
with you're like you or listen to you
you want that specific target audience
to like for instance can you imagine if
let's just say I'm Kelly Nishimoto and I
have my cute booty brand right would it
make any sense for my audience to be
marketing to 48 year old men not at all
right it imagine if I am a 22 year old I
want my target audience to be 22 year
olds and I'm going to you know senior
homes and I'm marketing over that I'm
not going to find a 22 year old so this
leads me to point number four is be
where your audience is audience is okay
this regard my handwriting be where your
audience is right be where your audience
is point number five be relevant okay be
relevant when you're when you're writing
stuff initially it's going to be
difficult to be relevant but eventually
like you look at Grant Cardone he's
becoming very relevant his periscopes
got I don't know how many people that
follow stuff on periscope is Twitter
account Gary Vaynerchuk
has become so noisy what everything he
was doing with Wine Library because
before he wanted to talk about wine that
he became so noisy so loud that
eventually he is now relevant everywhere
it doesn't matter what it is he became
relevant it doesn't happen overnight
this is a process and most people when
they create the platform they get a
little bit frustrated because they
wanted happen overnight it doesn't but
your goal is to eventually become
irrelevant right six ten o'clock news
let me explain what I mean by 10 o'clock
news 10 o'clock news is a lot of people
write a blog and you don't see something
for six more months then they write
another one then they write another one
within two days then they don't write
them for three months look I tell our
team 10 o'clock news happens every night
you remember growing up it was a 10
o'clock news everybody watched it that's
how your content needs to be it needs to
be like the 10 o'clock news every day
specific time or every you know week you
write your article on Sunday night it
needs to go out you produce your videos
on Tuesdays Thursdays it needs to go out
but it needs to be like the 10 o'clock
news consistency 7 authentic ok
authentic you ever hear of people say be
different you ever heard these campaigns
be different be some you know be
different don't be like everybody else
well the best way for you to be
authentic is to be you did that make
sense the only person that knows how to
be you is you so the more authentic
you're going to be you the more
authentic you're going to be the more
different you're going to be than
everybody else but if you watch
someone's video and you say I'm going to
speak like Gary Vaynerchuk I'm going to
speak like Tony rahmanir speak like
grant I'm going to speak like tyre I'm
going to speak like Pat I'm going to
speak like it does you be you you be
authentic the way you are if you're not
loud if your tone is lower whatever it
is you be you and the last one is
transparency transparency if you make
mistakes talk about it if you're not
doing something that didn't work for you
talk about it be transparent about it if
you're coming across as being too
perfect you don't connect what everybody
be transparent about things that you're
doing we didn't do podcast for a long
time we made a lot of mistakes for
YouTube initially trying
do everything for everybody we got more
specific - now we talk about
specifically startup entrepreneurship is
what our message is about in anything
around startup entrepreneurship is what
we talk about but that was about
becoming more specific become more
transparent viewers like you to be
transparent instead of trying to be
somebody or not so these are some of the
basic things that you have now to look
at social media in a different way and
to figure out your formula on how to
stand out on social media as an
entrepreneur now some of you may say
well Pat I don't know how to get my
message my opinion you know this to be
very clear for me this is what I would
tell you to do in 2003 I got my hands on
a set of 83 questions that I went to a
beach that I used to go to every Sunday
and I took these questions with six
hours and I went through answering all
these questions and I had a breakthrough
myself and I decided about three months
ago to make those questions public on my
website and when I tell you hundreds of
people have taken and they send me
private messages these questions did
this for me I got so clear on what I'm
doing it's a free eighty-three questions
but read the instructions before you go
to the record don't skim through the
questions to be effective you will need
to go through on one by one by one don't
go all the way to the bottom and work
your way back up like we used to do
before if you're serious about really
wanting to build a brand and really want
to have a breakthrough go through those
questions Mario let's make sure to put a
link on the bottom it's going to be on
the description if you're watching
YouTube if you're watching on my website
it'll probably be on the link you'll see
it as well and then from there if you
haven't subscribed to this channel be
sure to also subscribe to this channel
if you got any questions about what I
talked about post your questions on
about